um i got a ton of emails over the
weekend
um and yesterday and today
saying david you're not gonna cover the
chris cuomo thing because you're a
democrat and he's a democrat and you run
interference for cnn and
um
have you ever seen this show before
because that's uh
number one i'm not a democrat number two
i don't care about the democratic party
number three i don't even watch
corporate media with the exception of
clips that are sent to me for things i
might cover on the show i don't really
care what's happening i don't care about
cnn i don't care about running
interference for cnn i don't know if
chris cuomo is a democrat i know his
brother the former governor of new york
is a democrat is chris cuomo a democrat
maybe i don't care it makes no
difference to me and the chris cuomo
story is a very uh important media story
and the story is
by the way as we already talked about on
yesterday's bonus show the story is that
while andrew cuomo the former governor
of new york
was being hit with allegation after
allegation of sexual assault
chris cuomo
cnn anchor
was using his media sources to find
information about the accusers
and was giving that information to a top
aide for andrew cuomo
and sort of helping to craft a response
a public response to the allegations now
of course you would expect
if you have a brother
who knows about how things play in media
and has access you would expect that
he's going to try to help you
the question of course is about the
appropriateness of him being on air at
all on cnn
on air on cnn sometimes interviewing his
brother
and cnn has now suspended chris cuomo
indefinitely and it is obviously the
right decision which
sir what are you're not defend
guys i don't care i don't care about the
partisan stuff i don't even necessarily
uh uh see this as that this is just
completely inappropriate new york times
article explains cnn suspends chris
cuomo after new details on help he gave
his brother
the cable news network's top-rated
anchor was an intimate advisor to andrew
cuomo in the last 18 months of his
governorship
the cnn
anchor chris cuomo suspended
indefinitely by the network yesterday
after new details emerged about his
efforts to assist andrew cuomo his
brother as he faced a cascade of sexual
harassment accusations cuomo previously
apologized for advising andrew cuomo's
senior political aides a breach of
traditional barriers between journalists
and lawmakers but thousands of pages of
evidence released monday by the new york
ag revealed that the anchor's role was
more intimate and involved than
previously known
um
mr cuomo's entanglement with the last 18
months of his brother's governorship has
proved a slow moving headache for cnn
which has stood by its top-rated anchor
even as a drip of uncomfortable
revelations raised questions about the
network's adherence to journalistic
standards jeff zuckers cnn's president
supported cuomo for months declining to
discipline him even after reports showed
he was in strategy sessions with his
brother's political team a breach of
basic repertorial conduct earlier this
year the network floated the idea that
he could take a temporary leave if he
really wanted to focus formally on
helping andrew cuomo
but now a very harsh set of facts came
out
um we talked a little bit about this on
the bonus show in scores of emails and
text messages between chris cuomo and
his brother's inner circle he repeatedly
offered advice let me help you with prep
he texted a senior aide he made efforts
to track down the status of pending
articles
about the sexual assault allegations at
one harassment allegations at one point
uh the governor's former top aide
melissa derosa asked the anchor if he
could check his sources on a rumor that
politico was working on a story with
more accusations on it chris cuomo
responded
also includes a report the report
includes a text from cuomo to the
advisor derosa
sent a few days after a woman anna ruck
told the new york times that cuomo made
an unwanted advance toward her at a
wedding i have a lead on the wedding
girl chris cuomo wrote in the text
chris cuomo later told investigators he
heard from a friend that quote maybe she
had been put up to it so listen this is
obviously the correct decision from cnn
you're not going to find me defending
any of these actions this is completely
inappropriate there are broader
questions in terms of you know the
interviews that chris cuomo would do
with andrew cuomo which were basically
softball interviews and sometimes there
would be sort of like
okay now i got to ask you a real
question even though you're my brother i
got to ask you a serious question
it's just all not really journalism
um and that was a problem from day one
and this is just completely over the top
inappropriate so if you're surprised
that this is the position i'm taking i
guess you don't know me you don't know
my show but i don't know
how at this point
chris cuomo
can really be on cnn in a serious
incredible way that doesn't mean his
career is over i mean look at brian
williams making up war stories and then
goes away for a while and just comes
back uh look at jeffrey tubin caught
masturbating on his zoom meeting and he
had to be removed from the air and he's
quietly back and so it it's not over for
chris cuomo but this is completely
inappropriate and if there's any
criticism here it's cnn didn't act
quickly enough although this is
obviously the right decision if you
disagree let me know find me on twitter
at dpakman and tell me as a reminder we
are now under two weeks from the next
david pakman show viewer town hall
all are welcome member or not all are
welcome to participate it will be
december 14th at 6 pm eastern time it
will be live only on the pacman live
youtube channel that's the second
youtube channel
make sure you're subscribed there it's
free
and if you want a better shot of getting
on with me
sign up at joinpacman.com as our members
do get priority but it is open to all
looking very much forward to it we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video